[Music]
[Applause]
all right let me get to Pat McAfee he is
busy he's got a show coming up and uh
the Pat McAfee show ESPN college game
day analyst former Colts punter
thanks for joining us buddy how are you
Dan I'm great with that song jamming and
isn't it just such good vibes such good
energy every time you hear it and did I
hear in the middle of that least
favorite Danette or at least respected
Dan at least appreciate what is the
actual title there voting today most
valuable least valuable most improve and
least improved and uh I got the voting
coming up right after our conversation
here
man I will wait with bait and breath
there to see who is having a difficult
holiday and who's that going in with a
little bit of a buzz I know I mean I I
could see that maybe ruining the
downfall merry Christmas happy holidays
to you thank you so much for having me
thank you for uh being able to dodge and
weave here I know your show is a
well-loaded machine and I was supposed
to be on earlier I I just saw my baby
girl for the first time with my wife we
had her first Like official ultrasound
yeah I'm so
crazy
Dan you guys just had a moment there and
I'm thinking
Peyton McAfee
I don't know if the names are now to be
discussed the wife the wife is going to
have a lot of say baby girl I you know
this is uh this is something that she's
obviously playing for since she was a
baby girl and uh I appreciate you man it
was supposed to be this afternoon our
first official ultrasound really I got
moved to this morning because the storm
is coming through so thank you for
dodging a weaving and least favorite
dinette Fritz for making a magic happen
I appreciate you as well so I think
that's what you you said on me I didn't
say you said it on me but Dan thank you
for having me on here you are a legend
you are the man and uh you've been
killing it as you always have been and I
can't thank you enough for everything is
this your first baby
yeah oh that's awesome can I help you
with any any questions I have three
daughters
okay
always always
listen always listen Okay and let them
know you're listening and don't judge
them they'll tell you everything but the
the less you preach the more you listen
the more they'll stay with you the rest
of their lives
okay I have a son I love him dearly my
daughters will never leave me but always
always just listen because girls will
tell you whatever you want them to tell
you
it's amazing I bet you're an incredible
father could you imagine having Dan
Patrick
one of the coolest things of all time oh
what what's Dad doing always going he's
going to hang out with uncle Adam
Sandler and then he's going to uh just
dominate Sports Talk and be the voice of
sports for decades and decades I got um
I have a lot of friends you know that
are parents I'm one of the later in my
group of friends to have a child and I I
was never I was thinking I was never
going to either I was okay with that I
was like you know what I was a terrible
child if I don't procreate and create
another one of those that's probably
good for society you know what I mean
probably good for society my wife though
Samantha from Indiana she just has all
the traits that would be an amazing mom
that had dreams of being a mom and we
got pregnant she lost the baby then we
got pregnant she lost the baby again so
then we would go through the entire IVF
process now and we're at like every
Milestone is like a huge deal for us and
uh I've had a lot of friends reach out
to me through it all and right before we
did the gender reveal we found that was
a baby girl I had my friends all text me
they're like now if you AJ Hawk told me
this he said
you know me and my brothers we talked to
our parents like once a month we'll send
a text he was like my wife will text her
dad every single day to make sure she's
okay you want a baby girl is what you
like going into the gender reveal he was
like you want a baby girl and I was sold
so as soon as the gender reveal happened
I saw the pink things fly I was like so
ecstatic I was like here we go let's do
this so thank you for your kind words
and if I have questions whenever she
arrives I will certainly send them your
way and also if we need a babysitter I
will send her okay this is what I was
thinking with the gender reveal you
could have gotten a football that when
you kicked it it exploded and it was
either blue or pink
yeah a lot of people do that these days
I don't know how many punters do
yeah you're right you're right like
actual pot that would have been a little
bit different but a lot of people sent
them to me and uh they asked me to judge
the form and I'm always like you know
pretty solid swing see pretty solid
swing we found out what it was uh we
just we want the classic just
um biodegradable little uh streamer
things in the backyard with family it
could have been a little I was thinking
maybe get and I was thinking like we get
Brock Lesnar okay Brock Lesnar will
dress in all blue trunks a blue outfit
and then we'll have like Drew gulak come
out he's dressed in all pink and then we
have Michael Cole commentating it and
then there's like a full wrestling match
with like false finishes like oh it's a
baby girl oh it turns out you know I was
thinking about doing that and those have
been done before in the past but we just
did the the exploding streamer thing and
when I saw the pink I knew that I was I
was probably gonna end up and obviously
there's a lot of work that comes into
parenting listening and attention to
detail and caring and empathy and
everything like that hopefully I'll be
able to knock all those out of the park
but yeah it turns it sounds like I'm
gonna have a I'm gonna be I'm gonna have
a best little friend forever uh with a
baby girl and I'm very excited for it
then uh football coming up this weekend
weather is going to play a role
how often as a former punter would you
would you check the weather forecast
yeah so that right there is your arch
nemesis you know what I mean I was very
lucky to be a Lucas Oil Stadium where we
had the capability of closing the roof
in the window but we didn't always have
the will with Jim Mercy as the owner
especially if the season wasn't going as
well hey brother they paid for the roof
and the window to come off like we got
to do it you know so then it became a
full-on wind tunnel in that place but
whenever it was a dome it was like this
is perfect the wind is the problem you
know rain for me what I learned with
precipitation like when it snows it
feels warmer doesn't it snow makes it
feel warmer I feel like in my address is
somebody that grew up in cold weather
you agree with that Dan or no I don't
know if I ever looked at it that way
like if it's cold as hell like Soul
snatchingly cold yeah and it's not
snowing I feel like it feels colder than
whenever it is snowing okay well it
feels like the the snow is the reward
for being in the cold
Bingo we can snowball yeah we can we can
do whatever we want to do did you ever
have a place that was like oh my God I
can't even believe I'm outside let alone
I have to kick a football
uh so we played against Pitt I forget
what year it was maybe in my freshman
year at West Virginia I think it was
single digits or negative I think and it
was yeah it was absolutely a miserable
situation for kicker and punter cold
affects it because the ball gets harder
wind affects it more precipitation
though actually I found makes the ball a
little heavier so if you can move it you
know momentum I think weight is a big
deal in that thing or whatever so you
could actually hit it further I found
out the wind is a nightmare though
tonight Jags Jets yeah over under 39 and
a half supposed to rain supposed to be
windy as hell at the front of this big
storm that's coming through that feels
like tonight's going to be old school
ground and pound football tonight I I
think that's going to kick off the
weekend of a lot of that damn is there a
topic that's off limits with Aaron
Rodgers when he joins you each each week
now we never agree on like I've never
I've never been told anything by Aaron
or Aaron anybody associated with Aaron I
guess like I think that's why I enjoy it
so much and that's why I try not to I
want to say ruin it but like I'll
mention everything that happens
everything that in me and Aaron are
literally
99 of our conversations that we have
ever had people have watched so like I
don't know him like I never played for
the Packers I I was in a golf tournament
at the Bahamas with him this past year
after two seasons of Aaron Rodgers
Tuesday I was able to hang out with him
out of Tahoe at that golf tournament we
were able to like kind of hang out and
get to know each other pretty much that
was like the first time we ever hung out
where people didn't hear our
conversations so I try to address
everything with Aaron it's just I I
think there's different times in how I
present it if I make sense I'm just
trying to give this dude who's the Mount
Rushmore quarterback in the history of
the NFL and probably the best ball
thrower in the history of the NFL I we
just try to provide them with an
opportunity to explain himself so we can
learn a little bit more about him get
his side of it and learn about this
anomaly that is him and let him address
things maybe if they come up so I don't
know it's mostly if if we don't address
something it's a thousand percent my
fault not on their side of it saying we
can't talk about that if that makes
sense all right final 30 seconds here
I'm Gonna Make You GM you can take
Peyton Manning Tom Brady Aaron Rodgers
knowing what you know about them
start your team
am I like an uber wealthy owner like am
I one of these new owners Walton or
Bezos you're the GM
oh well
if I don't want to do anything if I'm
lazy I'm learning I'm Byron Peyton right
Peyton's just Peyton's just doing it
like I'm just letting him do everything
uh Tom Brady I feel like that's a guy
you want to have in your building
ultimate competitor uh Aaron Rodgers so
good at throwing a ball who's my coach
do I have I hired a coach yet uh Tony
dungey's your coach
wow damn honestly that's a fascinating
thing isn't it because I feel like Tony
and Aaron would have a much better
relationship than maybe Tony and Tom you
know and then Peyton and Tony had a
great relationship uh
it's my full-time job GM's fooled my
full-time job she has a full-time job
yeah yeah
nothing else there's nothing else if I
lose my mind it's not like you have a
radio job you're a GM
I have no other talents no general
manager is all I got
so I'm going to be pretty well invested
give me just answer the question I did I
did give me Aaron I'm invested give me
Aaron give me Aaron I'm invested if I
want to check out you know if I want to
check out give me Peyton if we have a
different head coach give me Tom but I
think I would want to be invested and I
think I get along with the guy and I
think it would be a good building give
me Aaron right now all right
congratulations on the baby all right
congratulations on kicking ass another
year thank you all right merry Christmas
I appreciate you that's Pat McAfee host
of the Pat McAfee show on YouTube ESPN
College GameDay analyst and former gold
splinter